hey how's it ah how's it goin Bros and
welcome to Rye sitting Havel today were
playing daughters which is an experience
of the beginning of the Baker's tragic
story let's play shall we here we go oh
it's so it's a VHS tape that's cool I'm
really excited to for these DLCs I hear
this one is really good
breaking news everyone keemstar here kid
one Felix rescue crews combing the coast
we'll have the details on that search
shortly but first what's the [ __ ] is
this what the [ __ ] it's a weird when
they went mix live-action oh my god what
the hell is in my play I'm playing this
oh this is before the shitstorm
literally oh my gosh she's normal I'm so
young sleep in poor thing
I say let them be okay here for a few
days leastwise - we give them into town
Zoe go get some fresh clothes from the
laundry room okay [ __ ] you [ __ ] I know
where you're at - oh yes let's get this
poor girl some fresh clothes and into a
warm bed well put her in Lucas's
overrule oh come on can't you put her
somewhere else
Oh Lucas you just hush long up from that
room always want to run a
bed-and-breakfast got your big break
didn't you get her to bed they're so
sweet oh they're all so nice good night
for soup don't you thank scuse me Lucas
yeah Lucas or did you place a trap
somewhere you [ __ ] [ __ ] there's a
change of clothes in the laundry room
dear
alright alright alright this is so sad
it's just a laundry room like I can't
bug in town this this room still looks
like [ __ ] to be honest hey it's a my
favorite lighter
assistant line arena room like what the
[ __ ] is the laundry room it seems more
like a laundry [ __ ] dump hole plus I
can't [ __ ] see without the flashlight
so that's great
wait am I actually I am actually
supposed to be here okay all right what
a [ __ ] weird way to go to that
laundry room maybe we can go just what
is this oh it's a table I didn't see it
I'm sorry
yeah suppose we could have just [ __ ]
walked all right here we go
how's she doing Lucas are you playing
flappy bird you're gonna instagramming
the carpet what are you doing I want to
see what it's saying some Facebook isn't
he
you're catching up on that latest Porter
patio all right dude yeah yeah oh my god
mom gee the place still looks pretty
creepy I would say but she must have had
us for a long time oh my god it's just
the bathroom this is so weird to
navigate oh my god if she became a
grandma they must have been a while
where the [ __ ] is our bedroom
it must be oh yeah it's this one we
remember this kid's dream honey please
get her cleaned up and just a dry
clothes I need to check on the boathouse
it's half on the water last I looked yes
Daddy hey he's wearing Nazi glasses not
the glasses here you go here's some
clothes oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] no give me
back my family goddamn piece of [ __ ]
girl oh hell no buddy it's a power out
hey daddy they're lightning strike is
that Matthew McConaughey this is cool
you get a little backstory girl get to
ah [ __ ] that girl that this is why I
keep telling you guys we need to send
off all little girls and boys all old
babies needs to just go to another
planet we need to send them to another
planet where they can fight like the
hunger games I've said it and I've said
it a million times
ok so the data is at the Boathouse how
do we get there maybe we can exit
through the garage daddy this seems safe
nope ok
damn that car it's [ __ ] huge daddy
loves this car he'd be furious if I
drove it what can I say the boathouse
where the [ __ ] is the boathouse hello
everybody go wait I hear someone mom mom
mom
what'd I tell you about satanic [ __ ] mom
stop oh come see her Oh God
jeez she got [ __ ] fast dude you know I'd
still hit it though honestly I don't
judge I'm into
centipede [ __ ] oh my god I can still
hear them jack is definitely into it I
mean what the hell is going on all right
shoot hey I got rope
daddy daddy needs to rope come and daddy
let's let's hang around the Rope Zoey
does not run she this is as fast as she
goes by the way what the [ __ ] stop oh my
[Music]
god we can't do that what are you
talking about what I asked for rope I
expect to get rope but I
oh my god you're so bald geez oh no
what's the matter honey don't you want
to play with your new systems oh [ __ ] I
died what how how don't you want to play
with your new sister okay you can't go
in now
God [ __ ] I gotta find a way out
oh god this is scary hey what about the
garbage oh great
okay there's this stop it
[ __ ] this bad for what already with a
[ __ ] fork you know it's the Annie
[ __ ] he's in what are you
oh my god he's so [ __ ] creepy
damn Danielle sorry no what's the matter
honey don't you want to play with your
new systems they must be away Eddie oh
my god there it is hey nice abs dude
stop it stop it
yes [ __ ] I don't think okay okay another
one come on fork I love you fork come on
boy
oh geez okay we're going [ __ ] wrong mate
okay we're going to Zoey managed to
escape in the story I guess well spoiler
it's not really what if we got here
watch out for those nails Zoey
oh oh oh wow
second thought I think I will nine right
what do we got here oh we can go up past
here okay that's cool whatever guy that
is toolbox okay so apparently I missed
something in the beginning of the dlc
where you have to look around a little
bit before you proceed otherwise you
don't get the right ending so let's try
and you're supposed to see a password
ominous phone fresh clothes from the
laundry room okay oh geez my name is
jacksepticeye hey a lockpick how about
that damn I never realized the ass on
that mommy she can't be in those dirty
clothes oh hell yeah damn she thickest
[ __ ] dog all right let's not walk the
[ __ ] stupid route this time
why is my framerate so [ __ ] low when
I'm playing this it's so choppy honey
please get her cleaned up and it's just
a dry clothes I need to check on the
boat house was half on the water last I
looked
yes Daddy more like [ __ ] nah daddy she's
a [ __ ] demon okay so there's a hole
in the trophy right so there was the
thing
oh my god it's Crockett now where the
[ __ ] do I there it is perfect all right
what do we got
please be a Bingle lot damn it it's a
smell component that's fine that's fine
we can do this together we can do it
together sing in a new song now all
right you don't want to sing that's
that's fine all right I don't care
whatever hey come down to Papa boy you
can suck a [ __ ] oh god she looks so
creepy everything you know I hope you
die fake-ass granny now apparently this
is like Lucas old room right so Lucas
you know wanking station was here
okay and the code was on his phone
hey he's making drugs here what the [ __ ]
is this
he was into explosives and stuff that's
kind of cool
I have [ __ ] [ __ ] Ulis the old
man slapped me right in the face for
checking my phone during dinner [ __ ] you
I can't say one word about momma's
cookie without getting yelled at [ __ ]
you all I did was look at Zoe when she
was doing yoga and she calls me a
perfect [ __ ] you
the old man got drunk and started
throwing all my crap in a red box out on
the veranda [ __ ] you oh that's the red
box okay tricky tricky all right so now
I think we can start the actual [ __ ]
process of this [ __ ] [ __ ] or
whatever
I'm all eyes at you so come look come
see her gift look at all the pretty
smile little girl it
kiss me
well my way daddy Laurie
Oh looks lady this is next to Gardens
meet him right now
oh boy now do you we can't do that what
are you talking about I expect to get
room listen daddy
into you
we
all right so now we should be able to
open yes hey it's a it's a dog dog head
is it all of them okay we need one it's
okay it's all right so it works great
fantastic excellent we're doing great
now we just have to make sure that we
don't done are you with me
that's right hell yeah daddy I hope it's
not his penis I hope it's not his penis
great how the [ __ ] did we get out of
here
it doesn't sound very pleasant it sounds
like some weird hentai [ __ ] happening in
there oh [ __ ] this door is up and now oh
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] where is she
that's yes oh my god no I don't come up
no oh [ __ ] yeah
Evelyn
[ __ ] off lady oh my god what is she
doing is she fighting her own vomit
that's a new one for [ __ ] sake [ __ ]
off are you yes I mean no
okay that's our chance
no no what's the matter honey don't you
want to play with your new systems
oh god oh god [ __ ] her
I don't like freaks why she don't like
sneakers what the hell man
have you seen my Yeezys oh god don't
come here
paratis I'm going for it
I'm [ __ ] going for it I'm [ __ ]
going for it I'm [ __ ] going for it
please for the love of God oh my god go
go go go go go go go go go
close the door I can't see anything
I'm running this can't be real this
can't the real Oh God where's the
trailer
Curtis [ __ ] gets it blocked there it is
okay all right hey what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
is MIA what do you got there oh it
happened
our bear sack great - the Baker family
thanks for saving my life
I can't move no no
[Music]
what happened what happened oh I would
stay light and it's nice I think I fell
asleep well well now look who's decided
to join us wake up and smell the shitty
coffee Zoe
Lucas you okay dear there's a lot of
excitement from that storm last night
I'm fine I had the weirdest dream last
night there was this little girl well
now after breakfast Lucas and I are
gonna have a look around and see the
storm that ended damage you two should
have look around the house oh okay well
we were looking and the next time of
rain there was a mess for sure
I do that's creepy
that's cool so that was the back story
of what happened to the family of
Resident Evil that's really cool I'd
love to see that kind of backstory see
her life has to become a struggle for
survival she's spent her days slipping
through the get brat of our now
interesting family searching for the
serum that Mia spoke about a letter the
night are marked by the family's
murderers fees ever leads bodied Tori's
as months go by eventually Zoey will
encounter Ethan her best hope of finding
the serum but she has a long way to go
before that dames and so began the
horror and so it began really cool
that's really cool I hope you guys enjoy
these DLCs I think it's so cool to play
there are like a couple like that are
funded [ __ ] around with but I don't
think I I'll cover them but if you
enjoyed please leave a like I really
appreciate it and let me know and as
always thank you for watching stay
awesome press